In 2009, the National Academies of Science
published computational technology for effective health care,
immediate steps and strategic directions.
Dr. William Stead, the distinguished head of
Vanderbilt University's biomedical informatics department was the coeditor.
The report states that quote,
"IT applications appear designed largely to automate tasks or business processes.
They're often designed in ways that simply mimic existing paper-based forms and provide
little support for the cognitive tasks of
clinicians or the workflow of the people who must actually use the system.
Moreover, these applications do not
take advantage of human-computer interaction principles,
leading to poor designs that can increase the chance of error,
add to rather than reduce work,
and compound the frustrations of executing required tasks.
As a result, these applications sometimes increase workload,
and they can introduce new forms of error that are difficult to detect."
This seems to me to be congruent with the results of
the physician EHR surveys we just cited earlier.
It's also suggestive of the concerns I often hear from physicians,
that their EHR provides a one size fits all approach to charting,
that doesn't capture the nuances of actual patient care.
In fact, the most common approach to electronic charting is
a template which as the report I just quoted
suggests mimics existing paper forms and largely
ignores the potential of a computer to be adaptive to the clinical situation.
The report identified seven information intensive aspects of
the IOM's vision of
a learning health care system that current EHRs often failed to provide.
I've abbreviated them here for legibility.
Comprehensive data on conditions, treatments and outcomes,
support to help providers and patients integrate
patient specific data where possible and account for any uncertainties that remain.
Support to help providers integrate evidence based
practice guidelines and research results into daily practice.
Tools to help providers manage a portfolio of patients and to highlight
problems as they arrive both for an individual patient and within populations.
Rapid integration of new instrumentation,
biologic knowledge and treatment modalities.
A combination of growing heterogeneity of locales for care provision,
including home instrumentation for monitoring and treatment,
lifestyle integration and remote assistance.
An empowerment of patients and their families in
effective management of healthcare decisions and their implementation.
This is a list of what I would call clinical deficiencies.
Many are of increasing interest because of
the new care and payment models we've discussed.
However, most current EHRs date from the era of pay for
procedure and emphasize support of billing and administrative processes.
These are complex large scale systems.
They're expensive and because of high tech now widely installed.
How might we fix or even replace them.
Here's one promising approach.
FHIR apps crafted to meet the needs of providers caring for specific conditions.
Here's an example of that for the care of
arthritis developed by the Geisinger Health System,
widely regarded as one of the nation's highest performing health care organizations.
Its user interface is specific to this condition and it can
display data recorded earlier by the patient, saving physician time.
Here's another approach.
The use of machine learning and specifically a neural network to enable the EHR
learn and adapt to the clinical approach used
by physicians to care for the problems they commonly see.
As shown here, once it has been trained on
a problem when the physician next sees that problem the Praxis EHR
presents their likely note but has
enough clinical knowledge to recognize what data fields must be specified at each visit.
The company claims that once the system is trained it actually saves physician time.
The approach seems to work since physicians consistently give
Praxis some of their highest user satisfaction ratings.
For some insights into the roles EHR connected FIHR apps may play.
We will now interview Tate Gilchrist's senior business developer
for Open Platform Services at the Cerner Corp.